at the initial idea for the film I was
maybe 10 years ago I saw an article
online with a link to a website it said
you could go talk to an artificial
intelligent program and so I went to the
website and had a chat with this you
know this program basically but for the
first 20 seconds I tie it you know psych
hey how are you good how are you doing
fine what are you doing sick I'm just
talking to you you wanted to talk to me
and like had this sort of like yeah
banter and I was like for like the first
20 seconds like this thing is talking to
me what it was funny it was responding
and then after about 20 seconds I
realized it was just sort of parroting
things that had heard before
and just a very cleverly written program
but like a parrot just didn't have any I
didn't know what it was saying and then
it sort of devolved into just repeating
stuff like Siri so that was the initial
idea I was like what if the man falls in
love as an artificial intelligent
operating system just you know sort of
based on that sort of buzz I got in that
first 20 seconds and then they didn't
really think about it for a while I went
off and made where the wild things are
but during where the wild things are I
started coming back to that idea more
thinking about it as a relationship
movie in a way to explore relationships
and then I think that's when it sort of
turned into this from the sort of high
concept idea to actually being about
something and thinking something that I
got really excited about writing notes
on and there's so many hilarious scenes
that just jumped out right off the page
so we oh we always it was never really
we always just kind of if a scene was
funny we always just kind of went for
the comedy of the scene and then what I
luckily our actors were so good that
they could kind of from that bring it
back down to a sadder moment or a more
melancholy moment and I mean there's
obviously humor and sadness and
melancholy and so I think you know with
Joaquin then and spikes voice as the
alien child we were able to we're able
to just say oh they knew that right okay
that was my cameo as actually when we
were writing I couldn't stop doing it it
was like Natalie who's one of our
producers would would be at my house
with me as we were writing and I would
just like it was it was so fun to be
that care
Maui I'm hungry maybe order food what
are we eating and when we were editing
you were do that oh yeah I wouldn't do
that it was give us notes as alien child
yeah it was part it was a way to like
released my anxiety you know just seemed
appropriate you know to when he's you
know in that place where he's in that
place in his life where he's not doesn't
have the energy to be social he's
heartbroken and just doesn't want to put
that kind of thing and deal with people
in that way just seemed like the kind of
thing seemed particularly right to go
home and play video games alone and the
and then and then in terms of making
that game it's just like I think you
know I'd loved in the end it was like my
chance to get to make a video game I've
never made a video game and and actually
the I really over over wrote the video
game like there's a probably I think
another six pages of story to that game
that we didn't even shoot because it's a
whole you know that's a whole story
about this this these aliens that
invaded earth take over or take over the
planet imprison us all and we're in jail
and we realize as you know this is the
only introduction to the video game you
know this entire thing about this aliens
have this collective consciousness and
we have to go to beat the aliens we have
to go inside the psyche of the alien in
their act and you and we've selected a
psychological warfare soldier and you
are that soldier and then you get
launched into this game and I think the
challenge every step of the way was to
pull out to make to could we pull off a
relationship movie where one person's
not on screen and I think that was like
you know I think that was yeah we always
just you know we wanted to we Eric and I
on Spike we all just talked about
approaching it as if it's he's having a
relationship with a woman he's just met
so it's not it's not about this other
being or this device so you know one of
our challenges was always how do we edit
a scene a dialogue scene with two people
but there's only one person on camera
and we we had all this beautiful laying
with all this beautiful footage that we
could cut to of
of kind of atmospheric and beautiful
like tonal imagery and we use a lot of
it but we we kind of realized that what
if we just hung on Joaquin he could just
kind of take you through an entire scene
without needing the cutaway to what he's
thinking about this mind because you
could just there's a scene where he's
talking to her in bed and he's talking
about he's met he has dreams about his
ex-wife and we we have all this amazing
footage of the ex-wife and him but we
would put it on there but we'd realized
that we could just stay I'll stay on
Joaquin and he would just kind of get
you through it without needing to cut
away from him all right when I sat down
to write I'd already made notes I
probably had like 50 pages and notes of
like and that's kind of the fun part is
writing notes like it can be anything
you don't have to edit yourself it's
like any idea is like a good idea and
you know like you don't have to worry
about how it's actually gonna fit into
the movie so that I had like you know 50
or 60 pages and notes and I sat down and
they'd say the first draft about five
months to get through that and and as I
was writing it I left a lot of stuff out
you know other ideas like that video
game idea or just ideas that of
operating systems in society and like
sort of I just kept going back towards
the intimate and going back towards
Theodore and Samantha's relationship and
and then and then probably for maybe
next ten months after that I wrote more
drafts I just kept writing until we you
know had to sort of lock we never
considered making her appear real but we
did consider in the same way we have
those visual fragments that are his
memory or visual fragments that are the
dust or the things he's looking at like
that's one of the things we you know
Jeff was talking about like how much you
know how much should we be on his face
versus how much we'd be on what he's
seeing or thinking or remembering and we
actually shot sort of his imagination
where you never really got to see her
and it was just not that interesting it
was it was a even as our shooting I was
like I didn't have that emotional
connection to it I was like you know
that everything else I'm feeling like
you're filming Joaquin you're feeling
even the dust I the dust I got that sort
of again that the buzz from like oh this
is exciting but I couldn't get I never
get like I'm said I didn't get that
feeling from
the woman that we shot and and of course
we cut it really oh yeah and it it
didn't Scarlett did such a great job
becoming this person that you can you
didn't you didn't want to you know we
always talked about you didn't want to
see a woman in the blue dress with
blonde hair or you didn't know what it
was whoever you were mad you want to
have your own relationship with the
image you create we when we were in
pre-production we started thinking about
how we were going to create future la
and I had this I was excited by the idea
of combining collaging two cities
together and so we ended up going to
Shanghai and using Shanghai very
specific curated areas of Shanghai with
very specific curated areas of Los
Angeles and I think it was an idea we
were trying to make this very warm
tactile world with with the materials
and the fabrics and the woods and and
create this this this world that felt
like this utopic world that everything's
nice and everything's comfortable yet
even in this world where you're
seemingly getting everything you need
and having this nice life they're still
loneliness and longing in isolation and
disconnection and if I had to define
what a picturing it would be utopic and
that sort of started this train of
thought which was you know sort of where
we ended up and making this world that's
comfortable and nice and convenient and
you know much like our world but just a
heightened version of our world where
everything is getting nicer as the years
go and there's more Design than there's
more convenience and our technology's
making things easier but there's still
this loneliness and